hello my name is Arlo I'm in GE Texas
and I'm going to try a trick and that is
to put a live brown recluse spider and a
live black widow spider simultaneously
on my hand for two minutes yes 1 million
of us have watched Arlo get a thrill
from holding two of the most dangerous
spiders in North America on his
fingertips but just how deadly are these
spiders he's bitten by a brown recluse
you could suffer from generalized
itching fever chills nausea vomiting or
shock and that's if he's lucky if he's
not lucky you could suffer from necrosis
which is tissue death the venom is also
hemolytic which means it breaks down
your red blood cells which can lead to
kidney failure and even death
and the famous Black Widow what kind of
damage can it do if you get just a
little bite and a little bit of venom
you might just feel a stabbing pain but
if you get enough venom the venom
actually contains a neurotoxin that
interferes with your muscles ability to
relax and depending on the site of the
bite and the amount of venom that's
introduced to the body we could have
some really severe effects here
especially if a bite affects the muscles
of the respiratory system where we
actually stop breathing potentially
suffocate that's an extreme case but it
is possible
yes our Loki is taking a huge risk so
why aren't the spiders attacking them
roast spider bites are caused by
accident if a spider happens to become
lodged in your clothes or the body gets
squeezed and they're basically acting
out of self-defense to make absolutely
sure that these spiders don't end up
squished in his clothes Arlo has in hand
sticking out of some water which is a
great idea because the spider isn't
gonna stay on his hand and not run into
the folds of his clothing well there you
go
proof that spiders aren't evil or deadly
unless of course they thank you
a spider has no reason to fight a thing
human what's it gonna do eat us